bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dédiée à la série The
Last of Us la première saison vient de
se terminer et je me disais que ce
serait pas mal de parler de la série un
petit peu car voilà l'univers de The
Last of Us est un univers que
j'affectionne beaucoup on en a beaucoup
parlé sur la chaîne à l'époque que ce
soit le premier jeu ou même le deuxième
avec de belles théories et je me dis que
ce serait bête de ne pas profiter de
l'occasion pour rendre hommage encore
une fois à l'oeuvre vidéo ludique de
Naughty Dog bon néanmoins c'est clair il
n'y a pas matière à faire de très
grandes théories la série a retranscrit
l'entièreté de ce que nous proposait le
premier jeu de Boston à Salt Lake City
et puis il ne faut pas oublier que nous
sommes face à une adaptation cependant
j'estime qu'il y a quand même des petits
éléments intéressants à souligner et
puis c'est l'occasion de parler un peu
de The Last of Us de manière globale
j'ai adoré ce que nous a proposé Edge
bio et sincèrement je suis très curieux
de voir la suite car les joueurs vous le
savez mais The Last of Us partie 2 est
un sacré morceau et qui a pas mal divisé
quand même juste pour votre information
mais du coup je vais devoir spoil
l'entièreté de la série The Last of Us
ainsi que le premier jeu mais également
je vais parler de The Last of Us partie
2 donc si vous voulez ne pas être spoil
voilà je préfère vous prévenir et sur ce
bah si vous êtes prêts on y va tout
d'abord j'aimerais que l'on parle de
l'existence même de la série The Last of
Us le premier jeu est sorti en 2013
comme vous le savez mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est que Neil Drugman le
grand papa de l'oeuvre souhaitait très
vite adapter le jeu en série genre dès
2014 au final le projet aura mis des
années avoir le jour notamment avec le
développement du film basé sur Uncharted
l'autre série de jeux phare de Naughty
Dog et on se retrouve en 2023 avec enfin
la première saison de The Last of Us
mais ce qui est intéressant là dedans
c'est de savoir que l'intérêt de faire
une série sur le jeu existe depuis bien
longtemps au final The Last of Us
partout
vu le jour en 2020 bien avant
l'apparition véritable de la série et
aujourd'hui on est dans l'attente de ce
que prévoit Neil drugmann et Naughty Dog
en fait ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que l'idée d'adapter le premier jeu en
une saison entière et intéressante car
l'histoire de base de The Last of Us le
scénario du premier jeu était établi
depuis maintenant presque 10 ans c'est
on va dire le corps de l'univers quelque
chose d'interchangeable et que les
joueurs maîtrisent sur le bout des
doigts et par conséquent l'adapter en
une saison cela permet de faire
connaître à celles et ceux qui n'ont pas
pu jouer au jeu de connaître tout ça il
y a clairement je trouve avec cette
première saison un désir de donner le
maximum d'informations au
téléspectateurs en adaptant le tout
premier jeu entièrement comme ça après
bah ils vont pouvoir balancer et par
conséquent je le sens bien qu'à terme
avec ce profond désir de créer un
univers cinématographique pour The Last
of Us et bien c'est que la série sorte
de l'adaptation pour apporter sa propre
vision et par la suite amener pourquoi
pas des éléments qui pourront alimenter
les futurs jeux je m'explique The Last
of Us partie 2 est sorti près de 7 ans
après le premier jeu l'aventure proposée
est très conséquente très longue vous le
savez pour celles et ceux qui ont joué
et nous savons qu'à terme il y aura
d'autres productions c'est des choses
dont on a déjà parlé à l'époque mais The
Last of Us partie 2 est un jeu qui avait
pour but de consolider l'univers et ces
personnages c'est pour ça que nous avons
beaucoup plus de protagonistes dans le
jeu qu'il y a encore plus de factions
que l'on suit plusieurs histoires à la
fois et qu'à la fin nous n'avons pas le
sentiment d'avoir tant que ça avancé
dans le scénario global de l'univers là
de ce que nous savons The Last of Us
partie 3 est un projet qui est
d'actualité mais nous n'allons pas le
voir aboutir quand même avant un très
long moment The Last of Us un remake et
là justement pour combler le temps et
puis il y a le fameux mode online
inspiré du premier du jeu qui est
actuellement en développement bref mais
de l'autre côté l’univers de la série va
avancer et c'est ça qui est pertinent
l'avenir de The Last of Us après le
deuxième opus reste quand même incertain
et du coup la série va pourquoi pas
permettre d'amener des possibles
éléments qui pourraient revenir dans les
futurs productions vous voyez ce que je
veux dire la première saison n'a pas
hésité à introduire des petits éléments
de la suite comme possiblement Dina qui
espionne et lit chose qui nous est
dévoilé dans le second jeu quand Dina
partage l'aventure avec Ellie mais
surtout il y a des petits éléments qui
ont été amenés et qui n'existent pas
dans le jeu et c'est ça qui met un petit
peu la puce à l'oreille tout simplement
par exemple le fait que Tommy va devenir
père dans la série cela peut paraître
anodin comme ça mais c'est quelque chose
de lourd pour l'histoire à venir Tommy
prend une très grande place dans The
Last of Us partie 2 on retrouve
d'ailleurs des petits détails comme le
fait qu'il est un excellent sniper chose
que l'on retrouve dans la suite mais là
savoir qu'il va avoir un enfant qui
forcément sera né et en bas âge dans la
saison 2 car The Last of Us 2 se déroule
quelques années après le premier cela
change carrément la donne Tommy dans le
second jeu va prendre tous les risques
va même frôler la mort à plusieurs
reprises et déjà que c'est quelque chose
qui n'est pas accepté facilement par
Maria sa femme là avec un enfant cela
peut amener un changement majeur surtout
que le fait que Maria soit enceinte et
l'une des grandes raisons qui le
poussait à ne pas conduire Élie à saute
Lake City quand Joël lui a demandé dans
la série c'est un élément qui pour moi
mérite qu'on s'attarde dessus et qui ne
sert pas seulement à démontrer la
différence de vision du monde et
d'espoir entre Tommy et Joel et c'est
même au final l'apport d'un nouveau
personnage je me demande alors si du
coup ce n'est pas quelque chose qui
pourrait t'arriver à l'avenir dans les
jeux si Naughty Dog décide de ramener
Tommy et justement vu que le premier jeu
a été enfin amené et digéré par le biais
de la série je suis curieux de voir ce
qu'ils vont faire pour la saison 2 et
prochaine car on nous arriverons au même
stade que les jeux or d'un point de vue
marketing ce n'est pas intéressant que
les suites sortent en même temps donc il
faudra voir si la série prendra une
route complètement différente quitte à
développer des histoires parallèles avec
d'autres personnages inconnus ou pas ou
si la série et les jeux vont à force se
compléter voir que les deux se fassent
aussi tout simplement personnellement
j'ai bon espoir en tout cas que les
prochaines saisons car oui The Last of
Us partie 2 sera adapté en plusieurs
saisons au moins deux regor du coup le
blason de l'oeuvre et notamment de
certains personnages le jeu a été
découpé d'une certaine manière qui
posait débat à l'époque et cela a
desservi le développement de l'histoire
je parle bien évidemment d'habits The
Last of Us 2 cela a été 50% du temps via
la vision de Ellie de quoi bien nous
faire détester à bille au plus haut
point et les 50% restants sont du point
de vue de cette dernière justement en
refaisant du coup presque le même
parcours ce qui a dégoûté un grand
nombre de joueurs perso je me dirais
qu'il y a moyen de retravailler la
dynamique et le déroulement du scénario
pour nous proposer quelque chose
d'encore meilleur vu que The Last of Us
2 se déroule en plusieurs saisons
minimum 2 Edge bio et Naughty Dog
pourront prendre leur temps donc de quoi
bien développer certains aspects jongler
pourquoi pas entre la vision des lits et
habille amené une belle origine Story
pour lève et sa soeur faire un épisode
dédié
Oscar ou plutôt les séraphites si vous
préférez ou encore le WLF le front de
libération de Washington d'ailleurs
petit aparté mais je me suis demandé au
départ si l'adaptation de David dans la
série ce n'était pas l'instauration
d'escar justement qui sont une faction
religieuse au final non mais ça aurait
pu d'ailleurs l'épisode de David je
crois que c'est l'épisode qui m'a le
plus marqué c'était vraiment incroyable
c'était tout aussi poignant que dans le
jeu en vrai nous pourrions nous attarder
longuement sur de grandes théories
concernant l'univers de The Last of Us
mais bon j'estime qu'on en a déjà pas
mal parlé à l'époque on avait déjà
clairement fait le tour donc si vous
voulez vraiment de grande théories je
vous invite à voir les vidéos que
j'avais fait à l'époque même si elles
ont quand même un peu vieilli néanmoins
je trouve pertinent de mettre en lumière
le pourquoi de l'existence de la série
existe car bien que The Last of Us soit
une œuvre qui se veut plus grande qu'un
jeu vidéo je pense très sincèrement
qu'il y a un but derrière tout ça plus
profond qu'une simple adaptation la
naissance d'un véritable univers
cinématographique nail drugmann a
toujours voulu voir son projet adapté à
la télévision et je pense pour de bonnes
raisons il y a clairement moyen que la
série amène des choses et rectifie des
éléments que les jeux n'ont pas pu
apporter et qu'à terme tous s'auto
alimente au point pourquoi pas que la
série devienne indépendante surtout que
maintenant les bases sont clairement
instaurées avec la première saison et
enfin en réalité on ne sait rien sur The
Last of Us 3 on a déjà fait pas mal de
théories sur cette future production
mais au vu de la double fin qui nous
était proposée avec
Ellie qui part de son côté et habille
accompagné de l’ave prenant le bateau
pour atteindre Santa Catalina l'île des
lucioles il se pourrait pourquoi pas si
les futurs productions ne réunissent pas
les protagonistes que la série une fois
les Jeux rattrapés nous montrent ce
qu'il se passe pour Abi tandis que les
jeux continueront de suivre Elis bref il
y a plein de manières d'opérer en tout
cas la mise en place d'un véritable
univers cinématographique et une
tendance qui est vraiment très actuelle
et qui a été largement popularisé par
Marvel nombreux sont ceux qui veulent
aujourd'hui créer un véritable univers
cinématographique que ça soit Marvel DC
Harry Potter squid game même Game of
Thrones Star Wars Seigneur des Anneaux
etc j'en passais des meilleurs The Last
of Us ne fera pas éruption à la règle
tout simplement car il y a des choses à
raconter et puis on ne va pas se mentir
il y a de l'argent à se faire The Last
of Us partie 2 nous amène beaucoup de
personnages plusieurs conclusions qui
n'en sont pas et donc plusieurs lignes
d'histoire qui peuvent se poursuivre si
l'on y réfléchit un peu aurait moyen de
développer ce qui se passe à Jackson
avec Tommy après The Last of Us 2 nous
montrer ce qu'est devenu Dina pour
suivre la direction Capri à bille élève
tout en gardant de l'autre côté la ligne
principale établie par l'histoire des
lits qui accessoirement pourrait ramener
encore une fois de nouveaux personnages
qui pourront par la suite être adapté et
prolongée dans la série il n'y a qu'à
voir comment edgebio a su donner vie à
des protagonistes comme Franck ou bien
encore la communauté de Kansas City dont
faisait partie Sam et Henri tout ça dans
les jeux ce ne sont que des personnages
développés sur des morceaux de papier
trouvables par-ci par-là bref il y a
moyen de faire des choses mais espérons
en tout cas que tout soit aussi bien que
ce qui nous a été proposé jusqu'à
maintenant que ce soit dans les jeux ou
la série
c'était une petite vidéo de chill et je
vous avoue qu'elle n'avait pas vraiment
de but particulier j'avais vraiment
juste envie de vous parler de The Last
of Us j'ai adoré l'adaptation des bio le
Paris n'était vraiment pas si évident
que ça car adapter une histoire de 45
heures en 9 épisodes de 50 minutes
environ bah c'est pas si évident que ça
et forcément en tant que joueur vu qu'on
a connu le jeu le gros pâté caisse de
Last of Us et bien on a un peu ce
sentiment de rush car tout est résumé en
9 heures mais en vrai c'était très très
cool à regarder j'ai vraiment adoré et
puis surtout il y a un vrai respect pour
le jeu vidéo que ça soit dans les décors
les dialogues et tout ça quoi bon en
tout cas perso comme je vous ai dit je
pense qu'il y a vraiment un désir de
proposer The Last of Us 1 en une saison
comme ça en fait on pose clairement les
bases pour tout le monde tout le monde a
accès au corps de l'univers et après
comme ça ils vont pouvoir partir en
freestyle et développer tout ce qu'ils
veulent en fait ils vont pouvoir
développer un véritable univers
cinématographique alors après il est
clair qu'à terme la série et le jeu
vidéo ne seront peut-être pas 100%
reliés parce qu'il y a quand même pas
mal de changements il y a qu'à voir du
côté de Bill mais il y a quand même
moyen que les productions se répondent
et que la série développe des choses que
le jeu ne peut pas vraiment développer
comme ça ça va agrémenter l'entièreté de
l'univers vu que Naughty Dog avait un
vrai désir de consolider tout ce qu'ils
avaient créé et apporter encore plus de
choses bref je suis très content d'avoir
pu reparler un peu de The Last of Us je
suis un très grand fan de l'univers
depuis 2013 et je suis très content
d'avoir pu encore rendre hommage à
l'oeuvre en 2023 si vous voulez plus de
vidéos sur le sujet je vous conseille
d'aller voir ce que je vous avais
proposé à l'époque en matière de théorie
etc et puis rassurez-vous aussi il y a
du concret concernant la série ou la
suite des jeux on en parlera vous pouvez
compter sur moi sur ce n'oubliez pas le
petit pouce bleu n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner c'était targorock on se retrouve
très très vite pour une nouvelle vidéo
allez ciao tout le monde
[Musique]